I'm sure that when I get home I'll
regret it I probably will goggle the
Emissary you should have stayed and you
should have done it man that sucks
American Idol contestant Sarah Beth
drops out of the competition during
Hollywood week it's wild this season of
American Idol idol is the best season uh
talent wise and then I was just I just
got the report from our our showrunner
that it's definitely the most drama I
feel like I'm not gonna hold that show
anyway so I might as well fans will
remember Sarah Beth shocked judges
Lionel Richie Luke Bryan and Katy Perry
last month when she revealed she's 25
years old and a mom of three
Katie no it's okay if Katie lays on the
table I think I'm gonna pass out three
kids honey you've been laying on the
table too much that comment landed Katie
in some hot water with some viewers
accusing the singer of mom shaming it
was embarrassing to have that on TV I
think that women supporting and
uplifting other women is so cool and I
think that Mom shaming is super lame
Sarah Beth saw all the chatter and
posted this clip in response addressing
the awkward exchange and thanking
everyone for their support I am grateful
for you and you're worthy and
um
keep loving your babies and despite all
that Sarah Beth's audition landed her a
golden ticket to Hollywood from Luke and
Katie
[Music]
[Applause]
flash forward to Sunday night's episode
there's a lot of guilt that comes when
you leave your kids to do something like
completely selfish bands watched as
Sarah Beth slayed her performance of
Roxanne by the police
Those Days Are Over You don't have to
sell your body to the night
Ryan but she admitted her heart just
wasn't in it this opportunity is really
Rad but this is actually going to be my
last performance because I'm my heart's
at home there's so many different
personalities and so many different
stories and everyone has that little
compassionate side of them Katie urged
Sarah Beth to stay you got a yes
and you may get another yes in the
future
do not give up but ultimately Sarah Beth
decided to leave we support them we
nurture them even if they don't win
American Idol they go home just like
full of so much hope I'm really humbled
and grateful all that Echoes what Sarah
Beth said on Instagram Sunday
the bomb of three shared that clip from
the moment after her audition explaining
that she was overwhelmed with gratitude
and shock it's gonna bring uh emotions
out and that could come in the form of
Tears anger excitement
surprise you know but there might be
some people that are just like oh my God
I can't believe it Sarah Beth says she
was actually scouted to audition for the
show and while the experience may not
have been for her she says in the
process she found herself and fell in
love with music again
[Music]